[Applause]
amid Ecuador's unprecedented political
and security crisis an unprecedented
snap general election illegal a
religious ceremony flanked by Special
Forces served as the final campaign
event for Christian Solita who's
replacing assassinated anti-corruption
and crime candidate Fernando
villavicencio
is
how can we explain what's happening we
are a country that explodes
as many drugs
reading in the polls by a diminishing
margin is lawyer Luisa Gonzalez from the
left-wing citizen Revolution party still
led by exiled former president Rafael
Correa
he was sentenced to eight years in
absentia on corruption charges that he
denies
from abroad he told ecuadorans that the
good days will be back under Luisa
Gonzalez
I see a country on its knees we're going
to start to put it back on its feet so
we can walk and then run in a year and a
half we're going to control Security in
the country the prisons and the borders
but the candidate who promises to use an
iron fist against Crime is 40 year old
John topic a charismatic newcomer in
politics the millionaire Economist and
security impresario shows off his
tattoos from recent military missions he
fought in the French Foreign Legion in
Somalia Syria and Ukraine and was
trained as a sniper
topic laughs off comparisons to Rambo
but tells Al Jazeera he admires El
Salvador's controversial president
naibuke
I don't agree with everything he does
but if there's something that I admire
about El Salvador's president which we
will Implement in my government is his
Clarity and determination we need a new
form of leadership with energy
urgency determined to do what is
necessary now
although ecuadorians have a lot of
choices the winner won't have a lot of
time according to the Constitution the
new president can only stay in office
long enough to finish the outgoing
president's Administration in other
words about 18 months after that there
will have to be a new presidential
election a situation many believe will
increase instability and in
governability here in Ecuador Lucia
Newman Al Jazeera Quito
foreign